Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activer la petite cloche.
il fait un froid de canard
enfin façon de parler
parce que j'ai l'impression
que les canards, eux, n'ont jamais froid.
Ils ne sont pas plus couverts
l'hiver que l'été
et quand la température
flirte avec 0°C,
comme aujourd'hui, eh bien ils continuent
à patauger dans la mare.
Je me demande bien comment ils font ?
Allez ! On va faire un tour
dans l'atelier se mettre au chaud.
On va passer cette histoire au peigne fin.
Les canards ont en
moyenne 14 000 plumes sur le dos.
J’ai pas compté, hein,
je l’ai lu.
Elles leur permettent
de voler
mais c’est aussi un ingénieux
système de climatisation.
Cette couverture leur permet
de maintenir été comme hiver,
une température interne
de 40°C.
Pour mémoire, chez l’Homme
elle tourne autour de 37°C.
Regardons maintenant
de quoi est faite une plume.
Avec celle-ci,
on verra mieux.
Une plume est constituée
d’une tige centrale
qu’on appelle le rachis d’où partent
des barbes et des barbules,
plus ou moins longues et
plus ou moins souples.
Ces barbes et ces barbules
emprisonnent de l’air
qui forme une couche isolante
qui protège le palmipède
du froid en hiver.
Cette capacité à emmagasiner
de l’air est particulièrement efficace
avec les plumes les plus
proches de la peau du canard.
De toutes petites plumes
très douces et très souples :
le fameux duvet de canard.
Bah ! Il est passé où ?
Il s’est envolé ?
Mais non ! Je suis là.
Je suis allé chercher du duvet,
J’en ai plein la main
et regardez quand je l’ouvre,
il prend du voulume,
il emmagasine de l’air.
Tout cet air emmagasiné
sert d’isolant.
Pas étonnant qu’on l’utilise
dans les doudounes.
Et les couettes, tu as oublié
de parler des couettes.
Oh la la! Il faut toujours
qu’il tire la couverture à lui!
Oui bien sûr,
dans les couettes aussi.
Bref, quand le thermomètre
dégringole,
le canard ajuste l’efficacité
de sa doudoune.
L’hiver, il redresse ses plumes
et les maintient gonflées
pour augmenter l’épaisseur
de la couche d’air isolante
et se protéger du froid.
À l’inverse, l’été, il peut plaquer
son plumage contre sa peau
et diminuer ainsi,
la sensation de chaleur.
Au passage, cette couche d’air
assure une bonne flottabilité au canard.
Un peu comme une bouée.
Cela dit, pour être efficace,
le duvet doit rester bien sec
et à l’abri des courants d’air.
Pour y parvenir, le canard
à d’autres cordes à son arc,
d’autres plumes,
des plumes de couverture,
sur le ventre notamment,
et celles qui recouvrent
les ailes et la queue.
Je vais vous montrer.
Les plumes extérieures
possèdent des barbes et des barbules
qui sont pourvues
de petits crochets
qui leur permettent
de s’attacher entre elles
pour former une barrière
coupe-vent.
Et ce n’est pas tout.
Ce grillage est imperméable.
L’eau ne pénète pas
dans le plumage,
elle est repoussée
à sa surface.
Regardez cette goutte d’eau.
Elle reste à la surface de la plume.
Bien ronde, une petite bille
qui glisse sans s’étaler.
Elle roule sans mouiller
le plumage.
La plume est hydrophobe.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Eh bien le canard possède
une glande au niveau du croupion
qui sécrète une substance
qui ressemble un petit peu à de l’huile.
Il utilise cette substance
pour enduire son plumage.
Un plumage qu’il lisse aussi
régulièrement pour maintenir
l’arrangement des barbes
et des barbules,
et entretenir ainsi son rempart
contre le vent et l’eau.
De cette manière, même dans la mare
il a les fesses au sec.
Ciré, coupe-vent, doudoune,
avec son plumage 3 en 1,
le canard peut donc
naviguer par tous les temps.
Enfin presque, tous les oiseaux
qui vont sur l’eau
ne peuvent rien contre
les marées noires.
Le pétrole colle aux plumes,
ils ne peuvent plus déployer leurs ailes, et s’envoler.
À cause du pétrole, la couverture
que forme le plumage n’est plus étanche.
L’eau se glisse sous les plumes,
elle entre en contact avec la peau.
Les oiseaux meurent de froid
et d’épuisement
ou alors ils se noient
car ils sont plus lourds,
ils ont du mal à flotter
ou bien ils s’empoisonnent
avec les hydrocarbures qu’ils ingèrent
en essayant de se nettoyer.
Reste une enigme.
Les pattes.
Elles ne sont pas recouvertes de plumes
et pourtant elles baignent dans l’eau
à longeur de journée.
Comment fait donc le canard ?
Eh bien figurez-vous que le canard
ne redoute pas d’avoir les pieds au frais.
La température interne
au bout de ses pattes palmées
peut même descendre
en dessous de 10°C.
Si ça ne le gène pas,
c’est d’une part parce que
les muscles qui actionnent ses pattes,
se trouvent plus haut, dans la cuisse.
Bien au chaud
sous le plumage.
Par ailleurs, les pattes
du canard occupent
une toute petite surface
d’échange avec l’extérieur
et ses doigts sont très peu charnus.
Mais ce n’est pas tout.
Le canard possède aussi d’un système
d’échange de chaleur à contre-courant.
Le sang qui vient de son corps
et qui descend vers les pattes est à 40°C.
Celui qui remonte
est beaucoup plus froid.
Dans la nature, les échanges
de chaleur se faisant toujours
du chaud vers le froid.
Le sang qui descend
rechauffe celui qui remonte.
Et ça, c’est tout bénef
pour le canard.
Quand le sang arrive
au bout des pattes.
Il n’a plus de chaleur à perdre.
Et le sang qui remonte
profite de chaleur de celui qui descend.
L’autre avantage,
en ayant les pattes froides,
c’est que la glace ne fond pas
sous ses pattes
pour regeler aussi tôt après
et le clouer sur place.
Bon, qu’est ce que je vais faire
de toutes ces plumes ?
Un volant !
Un volant ?
Comment ça un volant ?
Mais non !
Un volant comme celui-ci, pour jouer au badminton.
Ce sont de vraies plumes
comme sur les volants d’origine.
Au passage, sachez que ce volant
peut être plus rapide qu’une voiture,
le record de frappe
a atteint 493 km/h.
Bon allez, je dois vous laisser,
pas pour faire mon canard,
mais j’ai un match de badminton
avec la petite caméra
et si je ne suis pas à l’heure,
je vais me faire voler dans les plumes.
Allez ! À très vite !